it's cringe report time today we're
going to watch people do their thing 27
years without kissing a girl it's really
crazy actually like none of my friends
have waited that long I don't think
anyone probably in the human history
have waited that long I'm pretty shy
when it comes to talking the girls so
hopefully like this can lead to
something I'd be a little freaked I feel
for this guy yeah I do you know he looks
like he looks like a Ricky Iglesias is
like autistic brother if I can give you
the first time baby my heart is actually
racing like my palms are sweaty hi do
you mind if I give you a kiss yes she
probably kissed him and opened her eyes
and she just thought it was like why you
still looking at me that would [ __ ] me
up if I was kissing her girl and I open
my eyes for a second she was just like
Harry come on awake
are you nervous yeah don't be okay
can you try it one more time you sure
about that sure highs for hit the same
position the whole time your first kiss
shouldn't be on camera okay your first
kiss shouldn't be with this much
pressure sure Oh like that's a first
part you add the amount of pressure of
the cameras yeah you're right you don't
know who you gonna kiss you don't know
you send me on camera like that what why
does he buy like that
bye I felt like you were saying goodbye
this heterosexuality did not say bye you
know wasn't awkward about this whole
thing was the entrance and the exit like
hey what's up I want to pull that up
hey what's up how are you I'm pretty
there's no flow to that Hughes's I bye
it's got enters and exits very
interestingly it's like American troops
in Iraq so the making troops they by
like that see you soon
I left you some flowers
poppy fields they give it like weapon
semester hey how are you bad was a
bastard
no pressure today I'm the kiss a girl
for the first time mm-hmm Godspeed he's
a really great kisser for sure
because I really have tried everything
with dating I've dated online I've
hosted singles events I've approached
strangers and random places so I'm ready
to try love at first kiss and maybe the
we'll be the magic I'm looking for I
[Music]
think I am definitely more confident
this time because I've already had that
first kiss out of the way yo TLC
straight-up trash
this girl is desperate trying to find
something that's gonna work her and
TLC's like amen
well I heard you've had a lot of
experienced people and it didn't work
out how about we give you someone who's
never driven before and see how this car
ride goes are you buggy
text so and not only TT that you put
this [ __ ] in of anyone publish say for
everyone to see my name is Jewish know
what it's like when a race comes up to
you and you're like does this person
have mental health issues hi my name is
Josh hey I like turtles
that was great TLC do my girl dirty TLC
did her dirty
I don't know I screwed up what I don't I
don't know what happened that was more
awkward than I anticipated it was gonna
be homey probably blasted it was geez
and that's a fact
how's it going good what's your name
what's in nice to meet you
can I kiss you
whoa whoa no that's oh man yes she liked
you mister she liking that [ __ ] I think
it's a mess right there she kisses like
she's being held hostage
yes like him I saw this on the street I
would think she's being assaulted I'm
not you okay this is not acting most not
this is real it's real [ __ ] this is not
acting no things he finds fine she found
her what they found each other what is
with these awkward silences that's my
daughter's dead
[Music]
maybe she'll be my girlfriend
you never know check out one kiss and
maybe she's gonna be my girlfriend okay
I'm mad at you ambitious live your life
you know I'm not mattering because I
know teenagers who felt the same way
it's weird seeing a grown man but you
know what we all get our own pace so
congratulations to him good for him
have you happy that but I just wanted to
see someone kiss someone and feel like
rocky after they climbed the steps of
that place in Philly yeah did it that's
how I feel rocky are you a world
champion no I kissed a [ __ ] this is a
meat locker and he's just kissing me
like dodging gloves kissing you felt
like that you felt like that what okay
so she wants to know why he invited her
back yeah okay cool because it would be
funny to I yeah I just want to let you
know that I got other [ __ ]
hi this is beautiful yeah so I had a
surprise for you that's why I brought
you out here so from from that first
kiss I knew it was love Roxanne you're
beautiful intelligent smart and sweet
Roxanne
[Music]
what no no they know Mon cher ah no sir
Madame de la Mancha say Ibiza buddha
amitabha's illa right brother
no that is that no no no no more share
motion from a kiss from a rose on my
kiss from a rose seal listen if you look
up in virgin in the dictionary you see
this nigga's face you see his face with
eyes wide open just
[Music]
I came here as a guy who never kissed
anyone before now I met someone that I
want to share the rest of my life with
live your life I mean it's weird to me
but I mean it's not me it's not my
situations about whatever that's a whole
heap a red flag I'm 31 and I have never
kissed a girl on the lips
oh we've like joked about it before I
like you're too cute we're saving your
first kiss for our wedding and a lot of
people are just like shocked when they
hear that like really is that hard to do
as if no one ever does it I'm just
nervous about just the actual
intercourse I guess I would say yeah
it's starting to hit that it's really
gonna happen I'm scared I think that you
should take a shower first and then I'll
take a shower okay and then I'll put on
my lingerie we'll slowly take our robes
off and then do foreplay watching
virgins describe this is like watching
your grandma describe the Internet it's
wrong just some random baby guy with no
upper lip just be like hey do you want
to know why I buried the body
[Music]
[Applause]
can we stop watching my kids can we
that's it for today's we don't listen to
what you guys think in the comments
below how do you feel about PDA and what
are your tips for kissing we want to
know in the comments below
[Music]
so I walk into the room and when I see
him I'm kind of wanting to bail a little
bit
I'm not matter look at his face when he
sees her
he looks like Wolverine who never joined
the x-men night this guy simple mode is
activated this guy's level 99 idubbbz
right and he's ready to go yeah that's
too much like he'd never seen a girl in
his life and also the sideburns that is
Rocky
I'm like bro you're not a shark what's
up going on on your face
this guy's like thanks for kissing me
you know this guy said paints for
kissing me thanks for giving you the
only thing missing
thanks for kissing me bye oh this is so
uncomfortable
hey you thanks for kissing me Thank You
Heavenly Blessed beauty whose beauty's
everlasting and also divine thanks for
kissing me
[Music]
I shouldn't talk to women ever I gotta
talk about this here okay I don't know
why
oh hey can I just said oh hold on all
the years that we've done videos
together I've never seen you others
uncomfortable
I don't like PDA I really don't like
public this fella fiction I really don't
like that [ __ ] watching people make out
I can i it's big
what happened is I I don't like it yeah
yo it's like especially if you make a
whole lot of noise like the [ __ ]
right there yeah you don't like it with
the mics in the throat no I don't I
don't you like that [ __ ] I cannot I get
you minute I'm from a kid from that kiss
some people's love at first sight other
people's love at first kiss from Keith
but you can't know someone's in Cali G
what is it from a kiss from a rose from
a petal Rove see singing
[Music]
my loose tooth was on that's a great
song
you know what that's always the only
reason I remember that shitty ass Batman
movie yeah remember with Arnold
Schwarzenegger as mr. Freeman the
freezer though yes yes yes that was who
was that who was the Matt Matt I think
it was George Clooney yeah terrible
terrible
uma Thurman was it one with Herman yeah
okay you remember when you have what the
room with the bus assemble yeah yeah she
was hot
sushi I don't that's the bestest I
remember a poison ivy poison ivy was hot
in a lot of religion it was yeah wasn't
mine
yeah wasn't I be a stress no no what Oh
actually watching my grandmother
describe the Internet is actually more
entertaining than watching this one by
guy my corner map a leaky tamale PO my
grandmother's probably the Internet is
actually better than issue yeah Liza
cannot communicate connect it oh that's
him when you got this Amanda lemon was
that